good luck arcat wahoo from canada the
canadian
eight
23.87 that's a strong uh it's just
really strong rapid rating for this
blitz rating maybe they just don't play
a lot of blitz
usually if you're around 2 000 in blitz
that's around 2200 this guy's almost
2400.
chess psychology defenestrates logic
yeah it does it really does
sometimes
if you want to see a
master class in chess psychology
then
you should watch
amman hamilton's
queen sacrifice
speed run
uh his he got up i think in his bullet
queen sacrifice speed run he got up to
2400
where he would start with queen h5 queen
takes f7 he'd start every game he got up
to 2400 and bullet he got up to 2100 in
blitz
on chess.com on chess.com by the way not
only chess
on chess.com
that is higher than my
normal blitz rating like my normal blitz
rating on chess.com is 2100.
okay does this move work
i think it does
check
check
takes
he had this move
which would have been a really good move
but he didn't play it
so now
what should i play
let me move out
okay
classic
so he's saying if i take then he does
this move
but i can play here first and then i can
take
and i also have this move now
but
i don't
think it's like super good or anything
so
i'm just gonna take the pony
takes
this is a pretty obvious move i think
i guess we'll drop it back
stops bishop b6
okay we'll play bishop e3
he
trades which is
interesting
and
now
i could play check i could defend my
pawn
but i don't really
i don't really want him to escape like
this
to g8
so i think i might play this move
check
okay he comes up which is interesting
so i think i'm just i mean i think i'm
happy with that i think i'm just going
to play knight f3
and
drop my king back
all right
let's go we made a 2387.